for this next section of the program
devoted to honorary Awards I'm going to
turn you over to the Academy president
mr. Charles Brackett
[Music]
at ten o'clock last night because our
bylaws specify the border governors met
to decide from the honorary Awards these
single out achievements which do not
fall in the categories voted upon by our
general membership but which seemed to
the board to demand Academy recognition
the first of these that for the best
foreign language film of the year will
be presented by a citizen of Hollywood
in the world who spent a lot of time on
the fighting front in the last war she
was awarded both the Legion of Madonna
and the freedom medal for valor they
don't make any medal for glamour which
was her other contribution miss Marlene
[Applause]
[Music]
the Fallen language film award goes to
the splendid Franco Italian film the
world of Wella pada
many people are buying a black your
evening gown
and the strivers are battledress the
acceptor of the waters wearing a black
energizer with bears always
thank you another token of friendship
from America to each everything
[Applause]